[Música]
quem comanda a sua vida
um monge muito sábio ancião aceitou o
desafio de um guerreiro muito conhecido
pela pelos pela sua inescrupuloso cidade
durante horas e horas
o guerreiro o insultou o xingou chegou
seus antepassados seus familiares eo
monge permaneceu ali impassível um dos
seus discípulos perguntou mestre mas
quando como suportar tanta impetuosidade
tantos insultos
o monge respondeu quando alguém te dá um
presente e você não aceita esse presente
de quem ele é
o discípulo pensou e respondeu a quem me
deu e o monge disse
é a mesma coisa com quem te dá raiva o
ódio inveja mau humor ou algum tipo de
ignorância a sua paz de espírito
depende só de você nos últimos três anos
eu viajei e morei em cerca de 35 cidades
em nove países em três continentes
diferentes
a minha forma de ver o mundo mudou muito
depois dessa aventura eu nasci em uma
família típica de classe média aqui em
goiás em goiânia
estudar em boas escolas spe ano fiz balé
e por muito tempo eu fui ensinada a ser
a melhor
há sempre dar o melhor e ter as melhores
notas
as melhores notas e competir sempre com
os meus colegas
entrei para a faculdade e fiz na
primeira faculdade que eu fiz foi de
farmácia
hoje eu confesso que eu nem sei muito
porque acho que era moda
foi quando eu sair da minha zona de
conforto pela primeira vez na vida
depois de meu pai depois de ver as suas
empresas
vidas ele entrou em depressão descobriu
um câncer e oito meses depois ele
faleceu depois de um tempo eu fui morar
com a minha avó e eu morei um ano com
ela em goiânia e depois deste um ano ela
também faleceu
depois disso eu me apaixonei me
apaixonei em três meses eu me casei e
tinha um emprego estável há quatro anos
foi quando eu me encantei pela internet
a possibilidade de mudar o mundo a
possibilidade de nos unirmos uma nova
era começava no planeta
nós iríamos nos unir em prol de um bem
comum todo mundo junto em uma rede era
demais
meu marido e eu fizemos montamos uma
agência aqui não temos grandes clientes
fizemos muitos amigos realizamos muitos
eventos
só que eu voltei para o piloto
automático
nervosismo stress com folha de pagamento
enfim não era aqui o meu caminho no
casamento começou a entrar em crise e eu
descobri que não era aquilo não era
aquilo que eu queria eu tinha que fazer
alguma coisa
bom vamos para a itália
vendemos tudo largamos tudo e fomos para
a itália
bom reconhecida a cidadania na itália
vamos pra inglaterra a mesma já morava
lá chegamos na inglaterra e foi quando
eu cheguei no fundo do poço e como da
primeira vez eu tinha que fazer alguma
coisa vamos para a tailândia na
tailândia
eu me encantei com o budismo budismo
ele me tocou de uma coisa que eu vou
porque eu voltei a quando eu era criança
assim de pensar que a gente pode tudo
que a gente quiser que está tudo dentro
da agência já sentiram isso eu sentia
quando era pequena
o meu orgulho que sempre me fez achar
que eu era
sempre me fez achar que eu era a melhor
de todas competir com todo mundo que eu
era especial naquele momento ali ele
mostrou toda a sua outra face
imaginem se todo mundo estivesse focado
em em superar a raiva o ódio a ganância
ea ignorância da vida sempre focado na
busca de um equilíbrio de um caminho do
meio e com atenção na lei de causa e
efeito porque o que você faz aqui vai
impactar o outro lá depois o thailand a
gente passou por alguns outros países
mas eu quero chegar agora lá no nepal
chegamos no nepal que é um dos países
mais pobres do mundo
depois disso tudo eu entendi que a vida
ela não é é feito no movimento
ela é feita no na nossa busca na busca
de gente achar o que nos move o que nós
somos e o que a gente precisa para poder
evoluir
a gente é preciso desconstruir helmes
construir completamente estando em uma
cultura completamente diferente da minha
para vocês terem idéia na tailândia não
tem não tem natal não tem páscoa não têm
o conhecimento que eles têm de jesus é o
mesmo que a gente tem de buda que eu
seja quase nada
o reverendo um deles é é comemorado em 3
dias jogando literalmente água em tudo e
em todos
então essa desconstrução eu eu percebi
que a nossa vida não é feita num efeito
na zona de conforto
sabe o nosso desafio maior é a gente
controlar o nosso ego controlar o nosso
inconsciente quando ele tenta montar as
suas tendas na zona de conforto
a nossa vida não é feita em tendas de
zona de conforto
até porque quando a gente para a gente
se acostuma a gente deixa de arriscar e
de tentar outras coisas novas a gente
deixa de aprender ea gente deixa de
evoluir
hoje eu sou uma pessoa completamente
diferente do que era antes
eu julgo - as pessoas todas as vezes
em um julgamento vem na minha mente eu
eu mudo a minha perspectiva e e
consciente eu mudo minha perspectiva e
tento não fazer esse julgamento até
porque o esse julgamento o que o
julgamento que a gente faz o outro como
disse hong
o que a gente vê no outro é o nosso
espelho então não faz sentido a gente
competir com ninguém
se voltar a competir eu vou competir
comigo mesmo é isso que eu faço as
pessoas eu quero me unir a elas pra
fazer mal às pessoas que vibrou junto
comigo as mesmas coisas que eu que eu
penso que eu acredito que era esperto
competiu sobre este preciso competir
comigo mesma
hoje eu sei que quanto mais experiências
eu tenho mas eu tenho que viver hoje eu
sei que quanto mais eu leio e quanto
mais eu estudo
- eu sei hoje eu entendo que é na
diversidade que eu me transforme
desenvolvo não faz sentido nenhum eu
ficar olhando pra fora santo que tanto
tem tanta coisa aqui dentro de mim então
eu pergunto não eu afirmo quem não está
ocupado nascendo e renascendo e tentando
se libertar tá preocupado morrendo e
preso a si mesmo e eu pergunto pra vocês
quem comanda a sua vida
namastê
[Música]